そこでこのまあ それほどは関係ないんですけど
まあ一応エピソードは一つはつけてます
あの お釈迦様の時代のエピソードで
あの お釈迦様は王舎城というところでね
ラージャグリハですね
その町に住んでいた時
あの竹林精舎に住んでいた時に起きた出来事
あのゴウディカという比丘がいて
その比丘はこの そこからラージャグリハ
あの王舎城に山が一つあります
まあ一つはこの石切 石切というね
今もありますけどね 日本で知ってるのは数珠線だけですけど
一つ山がありまして 石切という山もありまして
まあそちらに洞窟があったんですね
カーラシーラという名前の
その洞窟の中に入っちゃって
あのゴウディカ長老が修業しているんです
すごく頑張るんです そこで瞑想がうまくいって
あのサマーディ状態 禅定状態を作ったんです
禅定に達したら 大体はもうずっとお坊さんたちはそれを壊さないようにして
更に更に修行を進むし
一旦一回だけでも禅定に達したら
出家した人はそれを壊れるようにはしない
守っておくんです これも大変な
まあ難しいんですけどね
ちょっとでも気が緩んだらサマーディが消えてしまうんです
ゴウディカ長老には何か病気があったみたいですね
あの 先天的な この病気のせいで
まあやっと苦労した だから瞑想自体も大変でしょう
それでも頑張って頑張ってサマーディに至んですけど
あの病気のせいで まあサマーディがなくなっちゃうんです
心は元に戻ってしまうんですね
体激しくね 混乱してくると
体と心はすごく整えてバランス取ってないとね
サマーディ状態は出てこないんですよ
だからそれで体がひどいことをしちゃうと
肉体が 当然心がそちらに合わせてしまうし
サマーディのところでなくなっちゃうんです
これでまたずーっと苦労して
またサマーディ状態はなんとかして達するんだけども
ちょうどその時になってくるとまた病気が出てくるところで
だから病気がないところで頑張ってるでしょうね
やっとサマーディに出たところで
またもうそろそろ先天的な病気が現れる時なんです
これであのサマーディがなくなってしまうんです
大変苦しい状態なんですよ
体調がいいんだから その一日
二日 一週間でも楽にいようかなと
それは楽にいない もう修業に励むんです
その時 長い年月頑張ったと思いますよ
作っても作ってもサマーディも壊れる
サマーディっていうのは初期的な状況でしょうね
心の またあとは大変長い道があるんだから
このゴウディカ長老でのやっとサマーディ至るまで
もう肉体は応じてくれないんですね
で こちらは七回と言うんですけどね
そこでも七回目の挑戦もしましたと
おそらくゴウディカ長老って命かけてやってたと思いますよ
七回目のところに挑戦して
やっぱりサマーディ状態をそれでも作ったんですね
そこで考えたのは 今度は壊せないんだと
これは サマーディ壊れる前に自殺するそうと考えたんです
で なんで自殺を考えたかというと
サマーディさえもなければ一般俗人でしょうし
俗人が死んだらどこに生まれるかっていうことはまるっきりもう定めないんですね
もうどこででももう生まれ変わる
だから瞬間の心で決めますからね
えらいやばいんですよ
私は結構落ち着いて立派な心でいたっても
調子が悪くなったらどうなるかわからないしね
一般人っていうかね そんな自己制御できるものじゃないんですね
だからサマーディがあれば自己制御できていて
もう次どこに生まれるかっていうことはそこでも決まってるんで
だから最低ゴーディカ長老がサマーディぐらいでも
仏教の世界ではもう一番初歩中の初歩の位かもしれませんだけど
そこそこだけでも得て
来世でも梵天ぐらいでも生まれてもいいんじゃないかっていう気持ちなんですね
こんな調子だったらどこに生まれるかわからないしってことで
だから自殺することを決めたんですね
決めて剃刀を持ってね
まあまあ こちらではベッドに座ってやったということを書いてますけど
どうかはっきりわからない
なんか山 山の上に登って首を切ったという話は経典に出ているんですけどね
こちらは自分横になって剃刀で首を切ってしまったんです
そこでマーラがこの 7番目の天界にいる神様です
神ですけどね そいつはそれ見ていて
だいたいマーラがずっと気にするんですよ
ヴィパッサナーが ヴィパッサナー瞑想する人だけなんで
他の連中では全くもう気にもしないんですけどね
6点 6番目の天界だからかなり高いところですよ
それ上の天界ないんです
ただ まあちょこちょこでヴィパッサナーやる人はもうゴミ扱い全然気にしない
そこある程度で進んじゃうと
もうやっぱりじっとしていられないんですね
気になって気になって
なんとかこれだけはいや
やめさせなくちゃということになっちゃうんです
マーラがそれで ああ これ大変なこと
この比丘が自殺したい
自殺しようとしているんだと
自殺したいと思ったことは比丘だからね
非 欠片も命に対しては愛着ないでしょう
これがまずいと なぜならば
もうひとかけらも愛着
愛着ないんだから この首を切ってもね
まあ瞬時に死にませんだからね
この死ぬ時間ちょこっとありますからね
その間でどうしてもヴィパッサナーやるんだと
この人は今までヴィパッサナーやらなかったんです
普通のサマーディ瞑想なんです
今までも失敗するに決まってるんだからと言ってマーラが落ち着いていたんですけど
まあただの私のるいふうは超えられる人じゃないんだぞと
だから魚が陸上で歩いて生活するって
こんなもう心配しなくていいんだっていうことなんですよ
もしある日突然魚がもうもうそんなこと全然気にしないでも
もう陸上で堂々っていることになっちゃうとね
それだったらやっぱり心配なんですよ
もしみんなもそうでしょう
魚たちがね まあ明日も取れるぞというえらい気分でいるでしょうに
もし魚の体っていうのは
たちまち足が出て肺が出てくるんだったら大変ですよ
ああ たくさん魚いるんじゃない
じゃあ明日取ってやるぞと思って
明日道具を持って網を持っていくと
魚がいなかったらどうしますかね
そこら辺の森の中で これだったら心配でしょ
そうすると何か薬でもつけていくんですよ
あの成長しないようにと
だからマーラっていうのは
生命に対しては全然心配しない
これ進化しようとするって
ヴィパッサナーに入って進化しそうになってくると
もうじっとしていられなくなっちゃうんです
もう逃げちゃうんだと
だからもうこの人はもうこれがまずいと
死ぬことじゃなくて もう命に愛着ないんだからね
どうせヴィパッサナーする可能性ありますから
これがまずいんだからやめさせるぞと
自殺は もし私の話聞かなかったら
お釈迦様につけてやるぞと
どう見たてもかっこ悪いんだからね
自殺っていうのは で まあ自分が言っても聞いてくれないかもしれませんだから
もうごく普通の人間のように体を作って
マーラがお釈迦様のところに行って
こういう風に報告するんです
マハーヴェーラマハーパンニャ
イッディヤーヤササージャラン
マハーヴェーラ 偉大なる方よ
マハーパンニャ 偉大なる智慧の人ものよ
イッディヤーヤササージャラン
まあ神通やらもう明予やらによって輝いている人よ
サッバヴェーラバーヤアティータ
一切の恐怖感 怒り 憎しみを乗り越えている方よ
パーデーヴァンダメチャックマー
目ある方よ あなたのあなたに礼をしますと
まずそれで挨拶をして
サーワコーテーマハーヴェーラマラナンマラナービブ
偉大なる人 あなたの弟子一人が今死にかけているんだと
マラナービブアーカンカティチェテーティ
死を期待している 今死を考えているんだと
タンニセーダジュティンダラ
早くもやめさせてくださいと
あなたの弟子一人がもう死のうと思っているんだろうと
でお釈迦様に言うんです
カタンヒバガヴァアトゥイハンサーワコサーセネラと
これって認められないでしょう
あなたの教えに出家して
あなたの教えにすごく喜びを感じている
アッパマッタマナソ また怠ることなく修行している人がセイコー修行を完成していない
いわゆる有学のままで
有学無学という二言葉ありますね
有学っていうのは修行中
無学っていうのは修行完了したっていうことで
有学のままでカーランカイラ死んでしまったと人々に知られることっていうのはあまり面白くないと
修行しようと思って あの人自殺しちゃったと
危ないんだと あの宗教はと
すごい仏教に対しては大変なもうお手になるんですよ
修行の運んだ人が自殺してしちゃうと
マーラがお釈迦様に報告するんです
マーラが報告している間に
あのゴウディカ長老が首を切っているんです
タスメン カネ テーデナ サッタン アハリタン ホーティ
で お釈迦様の前でいくら変身してきたってもね
まあ分かりますからね
だいたい人間っていうのはどうしても顔二つですからね
簡単ですよ 本音わかるのは
見せてる顔の反対だからね
だから上手に演技をすればするほど分かりやすいんです
で マーラがちょこっと押さかったんです
お釈迦様はマーラであるということも今知っていたし
お釈迦様の答え エヴァンヒ ディーラ クッバンティ ナワ カンカンティ ジービ ナワ カンカンティ ジービタン ディーラ エヴァンヒ クッバンティ
智慧のある人々はそういうふうにもしますよと
自殺はバカだけやるものじゃなくて
智慧のある人々も場合によってそういうことをしますよと
彼ら命に対して執着はないんだと
サムーラ タンハン アッブイヤ ゴウディコ パレニッドと
この割愛をね 全て足してゴウディカが涅槃に入られたようとマーラに言うんです
今涅槃に入られたんだよと
で マーラが別の意味で来たんですけど
お釈迦様にはそれは大事なニュースで
お釈迦様にとってはゴウディカ長老が亡くなられた
涅槃に入られたということで
じゃあ葬式しなくちゃということだけになったんですね
で お釈迦様は比丘たちと一緒に
じゃあカーラシラという洞窟の方に行きましょうと行ったんです
そこで亡くなったら だいたいどこかで生まれ変わるはずでしょうし
これ調べるためには もうゆっくり調べたってもよろしいんです
瞬時にどこに生まれたかということは
それはもうなかなか言いにくいんです
その生まれた場所でそれなりの命として形成してもらわないと
認識できるぐらいのエネルギーはないんですよ
お釈迦様みたいな方々だったら
亡くなった人はこの人はあちら行ったということを言えますけどね
他の人々は 大体二 三週間
1ヶ月間ぐらい調べたところで
あちらに今コテシてるですということに分かりますけどね
それでマーラがゴウディカさんが自殺しちゃったんだからね
これ心配やと どこに生まれたかと調べなくちゃと
言って 大体そこら辺なんですけどね
大体人間の執着っていうのは
自分も住んでいる環境の範囲で問われますからね
どうせろくな認識範囲って狭いのがいいところでしょう
だから大体どこに生まれ変わったかというのは
そこら辺を調べればね
見つかるんですよ だから知識次元というのはかなり幅広くしておかないと
ここら辺に生まれたいと思っていたってもね
そんな生まれることはできないし
日本だったらもう繁殖能力はもうほとんどなくなっているし
だからもう毒ばっかり食べてるんだから
生まれません だからどこかに幽霊とか餓鬼とかね
そうなっちゃうんです
大体これというのは どんな人間でも同じ
自分のこの範囲以外は物事を考えないんですよ
国際人にはなかなかなれません
外国人 日本にいるでしょうね
いたっても国際人にはなかなかなれませんね
そこでこのマーラがあっちこっち
あっちこっち あっちこっち行ったり来たり
行ったり来たり 行ったり来たり
この地方八方調べるんです
認識をチェック キャッチしてやるぞと
このゴウディカ長老の
で なんかちょこっと暗い煙のように見えるんです
それが ちょっと透明なんですけど
ダーククラウドというか
暗い煙というか 暗い雲のような感じで
一つ時々固まったり 時々サーッと広げたり
またじっと固めたり 上下一方あっちこっち行ったり来たりと
もう お釈迦様はその時ビクララには「あれ見えますか」と 「
あれマーラですね 今このゴウディカさんがね
どこへ生まれ変わったか調べているんです」と
本人には見つからないんですね
もう知識範囲は超えてますからね
それでマーラがもうこれどうしても知りたいんですね
で 子供の体になって で
お釈迦様に聞くんですよ
ウッダン アドーチャ ティリヤンチャ ディサーヌ ディサー ディサース ワハン アンウェーサン
上下上下いろいろ 四方八方東西南北
いわゆる時間論で空間論で言うんですよ
で 心っていうのはもう一応無色界に育てないと
生まれる場所っていうのは空間論でもうつかめます
心は一応物質に依存するんだからね
物質に依存するということは空間取るんです
で 無色界に瞑想しちゃうと物質の依存は切っちゃうんだから
空間は取れないんです
で その場合はなかなかコンタクトはできないんです
しかし まあ悟ってないんだったら
もうマーラさんでもそれでもわかりますね
これすごい自分たちと上の方になってますけど
悟ってはないんだと そういうことで
ゴウディカ長老のことはゴウディカ長老もそんな高い禅定を得たわけでもないし
初歩の禅定でしょうし
そこら辺にいるでしょうと
私は調べたんですけど
ナーディガッチャイ見つかりませんよと
ですから釈尊に聞く コヒン
ゴウディカソウ コヒンガと
ゴウディカがどこへ行ったのでしょうかと
お釈迦様の答え ソウディーロ ディティサンパンノ
その賢者はディティサンパンノっていうのはまた同じ智慧があるということで
あるいはこのすごい精進する勇気のある人が
ジャハイ ジャハナ ラトウ サダ
常に修行して ジャハナ禅定にすごく目指して頑張っていた人であると
アホーラッタン アヌユンジャン ジーヴィタン アニカーメヤン
昼も夜も精進しましたと
命には何の執着もなかったと
ジッワナ マッチュノーセーナンマーラの軍隊に勝ってアナアガントア プナッバーナもう再び生まれることはないんだと
再生しないってことになりましたと
サムーラン タンナン割はなくなりましたと
アッブイヤゴーディ アッブイヤゴーディクワ パリニブトゴーディカが涅槃に入られたんだよと
だからもうマーラさんの負けなんです
涅槃 それだけ嫌でしたけど
それになってしまったんです
で マーラがすっごいそこで負けたというショック受けちゃって
あのマーラさんがいつでもある楽器持ってるんですよ
あの まあヴィーナーというんですけど
まあベールオパンダという名前まであります
まあなんでしたっけ？バイオリンの一番高いやつの名前は
あの何ヴィーラ 何だったっけ
え？ストラディも何とかいうね
カタカナの発音できないんだからね
あれ何千万もかかっちゃう
あんなもうこれは花見鼻差持ってるんです
だから子供の形に変えてもこれ持ってるんですよ
だからすぐバレるんですよ
まあたとえ神でも まあそこの部分なもんですよ
バカはバカですからね
そこなこと まあ時間的に我々よりいろんなことは知ってはいるんですけど
まあよくない あっぱれとかできません
だからマーラでもね まあ人にあっぱれすることは全くないんですけども
お釈迦様ともこのあれ
楽器だけは持ってるんですね
それでお釈迦様がもうゴーディカはもう涅槃に入られたと言った途端
何か暗くなっちゃって
あの あの楽器が落ちちゃったんだと
二 三回は記録していますよ
二 三回かな もう楽器はこちらもう固めて
それで落ちちゃったと
それですぐそこで消えてしまったんですね
マーラが  そのエピソードに関係ある芸としてこちらで言ってますけどね
それぐらい十分でしょう
今日はもうまた続くんですから
[紙をめくる音]これで五十七番目だったっけ
そういう意味で回り返してください
それで言いたがっているのは
悟りの道を語ってますよ
何のことなく順番にすごい短い言葉で
一切の概念超えているところっていうことでね
概念で理解できなかったら存在しないぞというのは
それは概念ですけどね
存在する 存在しないという両方の概念にも当てはめません
[背景音]